thank you so much for the introduction
and
hi everyone great to be here thanks so
much for having me it's great to
see a new group of people on a meeting
that's not the same group of people that
i see
every day or every week so this is
really exciting for me really enjoyed
the conversations
that i've had so far and the
conversations i'll be able to have later
as well
so let me go ahead and share my screen
here
okay i'm assuming people can see that
we're good to go okay
oh so so like michael said um the the
title of my talk today and the topic
overall is going to be around
accessible virtual reality for people
with limited mobility
so i'm going to get into that but first
i kind of wanted to be able to provide
just a little bit more background
about me who i am so uh
starting off a little bit my educational
background so before i was at the
university of washington
i received my bachelor's and master's in
computer science from bowling green
state university
bowling green is a small college town in
um
in ohio um that is close to home i'm
from detroit originally so that was
really great for me
um and then after that i left and went
to washington so i got my phd
in the in information science from the
information school at the university of
washington in 2018
and then after leaving there i joined
first as a postdoc
in the ability group at microsoft
research and i'm now currently a
senior researcher in a group since the
last
three or four months or so
and this is just a quick overview of the
other people on the ability team some of
the people here's research
um you're going to hear mentioned this i
talk about the different stuff that
we've been working on so there's
andy bagel at couture sasha universe
myself and john ton
so i want to start off by providing an
overview of what my talk is going to
entail today
so first anytime i'd like to do any of
these presentations i always like to
talk a little bit about accessible
computing i think accessibility
is something that people might have some
idea around but i don't think it's
something that's as core
to our hci knowledge as it should be and
i know you've had
patrick and other people patrick
carrington and other people this um
quarter give talk so then there may be
things that you've heard already in this
space but
i think when it comes to accessibility i
don't think you can hear it too many
times so i'll talk a little bit about
some how i think about accessible
computing and then i'm going to
lead that into kind of how does my
thoughts about accessibility or
accessible computing how does that
inform my research so i'm going to talk
a little bit
about my overall research approach and
then from there i'm going to talk about
this notion of how do we move more
towards accessible
vr primarily for people with limited
mobility
and since this is ongoing work and
things that are in flux
and since kind of midway through
me working on this work you know we went
through this you know shutdown with the
covet pandemic and everything so a lot
of the work that i would prefer to do of
like
in person co-design type of things we're
not able to do
you know essentially over the past year
or so due to the
stay-at-home orders and the social
distancing restrictions and things like
that
but i'm gonna my plan there is to give
you an overview or at least a little bit
of information about some of the
interesting problems that we've
identified in this space and i would
love to kind of just have a
broader conversation about what that
might entail for more accessible vr
interactions in the future
and then i'm going to end kind of
talking about some other opportunities
that exist so some things that are
outside
my media research area but things that i
think would be
really great in fruitful areas of
research that people could
chat about so that's the overview of the
talk um and i'm not sure how q a or
things are going to go
exactly but i'm okay if
there is something that i say and you
want to interrupt me and ask a question
that's usually okay with me so just let
me know but
if we want to wait to the end to do
questions that works as well so
um so first all right i'm going to start
off talking a little bit about
accessible computing and kind of how i
think about accessible computing
so i kind of like to start off with this
definition
which is to say that um i really think
about accessibility in these kind of two
ways so one is this notion of like well
how can we design computing devices and
services to be usable by all people
and then the second part of that is you
know well how can we use computing to
also make the world more accessible to
people with disabilities so you can
really look at accessibility
in these two different ways and there's
been
a lot of great work for a lot of years
looking at well how can we think about
accessible design and what does that
mean to incorporate
accessible design into the development
of technology
so one really popular method that people
have employed to do that is to look at
universal design
so i have a definition here from
universal design which says that
it's really the design of products and
environments that can be used and
experienced by people of all ages and
abilities
to the greatest extent possible without
adaptation and the thing to notice about
universal design is that it really comes
out of architecture discipline so
it really you could think of it as like
well how can we make built environments
more accessible
and you know how we can have people be
able to experience these things
without requiring adaptation and then
when it comes to things
you know using universal design to
create more accessible technologies it
just kind of gives you a lot of great
stuff right so
you can think of curb cuts it's like a
great example universal design is
probably the most canonical example that
people use often so
you can make card cuts you can make it
easier for people who use
wheelchairs or other implements to be
able to
you know navigate safely from the
sidewalk to the street but then you're
gonna also get these carryover benefits
that you know
great for people on skateboards a
bicycle is a person pushing a stroller
et cetera
and the same thing with closed
captioning so we can have text that
represents
audio that's happening on whatever
program we might be watching
which is really great because you can
make this content more accessible to
people
who may be deaf hard of hearing but it's
also great if you're like
up really late at night trying to get
like a baby to sleep but you want to
just put something on the tv and you
just turn
closed captioning on right or you're in
a really crowded restaurant well
in the past life you were a really
crowded restaurant and you wanted to
watch something on tv you would put the
closed captionings on
so so great stuff universal design gives
us
so but if we go back to this definition
and we interrogate a little bit more it
asks this really interesting question so
i'm just going to read the definition
again
so it says the design of products and
environments that can be used and
experienced by people of all ages and
abilities to the greatest extent
possible without adaptation
um so there's this really heavy emphasis
that i put in a slide here on abilities
because it begs this question like well
what is ability in this case how do we
think about ability how do we
measurability what do we do with ability
um
so one of the ways that's really useful
and
that's been influential to the way i
think about accessibility research
is to incorporate a design approach
called
callability based design so
ability-based design is
a designed approach that was formulated
by
jake robrock and colleagues jake was my
advisor when i was at the university of
washington
and in ability-based design what it does
is that it gives
computer systems options to understand
what human abilities are required to
operate an interactive system
and they're questioned and then you want
to understand how systems can adapt or
be adapted to these alternative
abilities so it really puts the
abilities part
first in thinking about how you might
want to design different technologies
for people
so again still this notion of like okay
well what is ability
and an example that comes out of this is
well you can really just think of
ability as
possession of the means or skills to do
something
and it could be anything whatever task
or whatever type of
action you want to be able to perform if
you possess the means of skill to do
something you have the
ability to do it and then our notion of
disability has also changed a lot over
years
so this is a this is kind of the working
definition from the world health
organization that they put on 2001 which
essentially shows that
you know disability is complex it's
actually not just something that's
static and it's not something that's
within a person
it's actually something that has to do
with different type of contextual and
environmental factors that actually
impact what makes something
accessible and what is disabling to
somebody in any given scenario
um so this is important because we can
look at ability-based design and it's
asking us to
ask these questions like well what
context is someone using this device or
this system
what what is the environment like at
this time when they're doing these
things and if we can understand
something around these different
variables we can make our systems more
accessible
as a result um
and i wanted to end with this last thing
here about ability-based design which i
think is really useful and it's called
the positive affirmation of ability so
what they're saying here is that
everyone has abilities some people
more than others and what's really
important is that we need to design
for people with abilities of all types
so that's kind of like this main
takeaway is you know once again
foreground ability make ability the
thing that you're trying to design for
so that's kind of my spiel on how i
think about accessibility and
accessibility research
and so now i kind of want to just talk
about like my general research approach
um so typically what i do is i like to
um evaluate what we call these ability
assumptions
so an ability assumption so if you think
about this all human operated
technologies
contain embedded ability assumptions
rather explicit or implicit so
that's every technology not just
computer technologies but
you know whatever anything that's been
made by humans anything that's been
designed by humans it's going to have
these assumptions embedded in them that
are going to dictate
how people are expected to use them or
how people can
use them and it's really important that
when we think about technologies and
either when we're designing new
technologies or trying to understand how
to make past technologies more
accessible
is we really need to understand at the
core of them what are the ability
assumptions what are we
and what are we anticipating people can
do or what are we expecting people to be
able to
do when they interact with these
technologies and we need to understand
how those expectations and how
all those assumptions are actually
creating systems
and applications that are actually um
preventing people from being able to use
it and it can actually be quite
exclusionary
so for my dissertation work i looked at
the ability assumptions and kind of
embedded inside the
kind of what you think of as just like a
touchscreen device
so there are some things that we just
kind of take for granted right the
affordances of a touchscreen and how
they and what they allow us to do so
we assume that we can do things just
like you know you could tap with a
single finger
if you want to select a target you can
like both lift and land inside of it
you could perform both you know
two-handed i mean
two-finger and single-finger gestures
like a swipe or pinch to zoom or things
like that
uh but what i found in my research is
that people are actually use all
different types of ways to interact with
the touch screen so
this is a research study that we did
back in 2015 because it was published in
2016 but
we essentially created this test bed and
we just asked people that hey touch this
crosshair that's placed on the screen
but touch in whichever way is most
comfortable and natural to you
like and this is all with people with
limited mobility
primarily people's cerebral palsy we did
the study at a place in seattle called
prevail which used to be united cerebral
palsy center
and essentially what we find is you know
like hey people might touch the screen
with multiple fingers kind of like the
way this participant is showing now
so they're kind of hitting the crosshair
on the screen kind of using their thumb
as kind of like the primary pointing
implement but still
interacting with the screen with various
fingers which in a normal case
would actually be really inaccurate for
the system because it's not expecting
all of those touch input
points um and you can also see people do
different types of like dragging their
hands and different types of behaviors
right so this is a person who's kind of
using the screen for stability and it's
kind of dragging her hand
towards her crosshair it's kind of doing
a little dwell and then kind of moving
their hand back
um so essentially this project was part
of a well this one
piece of the project was part of a
bigger research goal which was like to
understand
how can we model touch behavior so if we
can understand the touch behaviors that
people use when they're interacting with
touchscreen devices then
we can train touch screen systems to
respond more accurately to people's
innate touch behaviors
and we can make these systems more
accessible as a result
but part of it comes from understanding
these ability assumptions right and not
just going in and expecting people
to interact with the system the way you
want them to what the way you expect
them to people are going to do things
that work for them and
we need to make those things work for
them in turn
so kind of my general research approach
here
when i approach a new problem is i
really try to identify and question what
these ability assumptions are so
whatever technology i'm working on
either if i'm developing a new
technology
or trying to retrofit a past technology
this is a really important question to
look at is what are the ability
assumptions
and then i consider myself like an input
and interaction person i like
i get really excited about thinking
about ways to create new input schemes
and interaction methods to allow people
to interact with computing devices in
ways that
maybe they weren't able to before so
based off this notion of understanding
what these assumptions are and
understanding what people could do then
i can take that knowledge and
actually start to create interaction
techniques that are actually more
accessible to people
and then the last part is actually you
know evaluating the things we build with
target users
which is like i don't probably don't
have to say it to this group you know
very important you know if you
actually want to create technologies
that work with people with cerebral
palsy or muscular dystrophy or
parkinson's
it's really important to actually then
go out and not only do the co-design
with them but then actually do
the evaluation so that you can actually
get an accurate representation of
how well your system works or your
interaction techniques work in this case
okay so that was kind of like the
background
portion of the talk so a little bit
about how i think about accessibility
a little bit about my past research and
how things are going so
what i'm going to talk about now is some
of the research that my group
has been doing so me primarily for some
of these projects but my group in
general what we've been doing around
trying to make virtual reality more
accessible like i mentioned a couple
months ago
it's been really difficult to try to do
this work the way we want to
given the restrictions of copen19 and
all of that entails
um you know i think when you work with
people with disabilities it's really
important to do these co-design
kind of activities and actually be able
to observe people interact with devices
actually be able to be there and collect
data
in a much much more rich kind of way
so what i'm going to talk about now is
some of the kind of initial stuff that
we've been doing kind of you know given
all of the limitations that we have
around covet but my real hope from this
conversation is that
some of the problems that i might
identify you might be really interested
in and it might make you actually think
about
virtual reality or more broadly how
spatial computing and things like that
might be inaccessible to people with
disabilities
it might motivate you or you know
encourage you all to think about
you know doing some research in this
space so that's kind of the hope of i'm
going to have from
doing this part of the talk so
just really brief kind of like
background of virtual reality so
um people most people following this
call are probably familiar with vr
you know it's an immersive technology
that allows people to
to be embodied in different experiences
and to
you know navigate and explore different
type of virtual environments
and offers a lot of benefits over
traditional kind of 2d computing devices
like you know desktop or mobile systems
really this level of immersion and
presence and
embodiment is really something that is
really hard to to
replicate um in a traditional
traditional computing sense so you know
virtual reality you know primarily used
for gaming
i think that's kind of like the biggest
market for it right now but you could
also use it for things like medical
training
architectural walkthroughs so the point
i wanted to make here is that you know
virtual reality just isn't
well probably won't be just a technology
that's just used for gaming and
entertainment
it's not too hard to believe that
actually you know people for their
jobs and their professions and
educational scenarios are
going to be using virtual reality for a
lot of different types of applications
and use cases so it's really important
to think about
how we can make these things accessible
because if the devices and applications
aren't accessible
then those experiences as a result won't
be accessible either
um so this has been an explosion kind of
like really like in the last
five or six years um in a number of kind
of commercial vr systems that are
available so
yeah and i have the whole like oculus
family of devices htc
now kind of has the vibe and the cosmos
and a couple of devices and then
windows also has a mixed reality
platform that
um companies like acer and i think um
like hp also kind of have their own type
of vr headsets that's running the
windows mixed reality platform
so this is an interesting point to
really
get into this space because vr isn't in
its emphasis anymore people have been
doing vr research for decades
but it also hasn't reached this kind of
like mass production or mass
adoption yet so there's still tons of
people who haven't had the opportunity
to try vr
vr systems are still going to be
changing in form factors and sizes and
things like that
but it's really really an opportunity to
think about accessibility
before this perhaps potential mass
adoption occurs
um so yeah so like what i'll be talking
about so there's this notion that you
know vr is really great for a lot of
things but
virtual reality really does has an
accessibility problem so this is a
screen grab
of a little clip that i have from a
scientific american article article
in which it says virtual reality has
been touted as an empathy machine that
lets users see what it's like to have a
disability
but people with disabilities often can
use it so it's this
notion here that um virtual reality
can have potential for example you know
for empathy training and things like
that
but people with disabilities themselves
don't often can't have access to these
systems
so a paper that i wrote along with
by cobra along with a bunch of other
people at microsoft research
we wrote this paper at the ismart
conference in 2019 called accessible by
design and opportunity for virtual
reality
and what we tried to do is actually try
to lay out the case for
well when we're thinking about virtual
reality systems and how we want to make
them accessible what are really some of
the things that we should be focusing on
so where should our priorities be and
how should we think about what we're
doing in this space to make these things
more accessible
so we identified kind of five key areas
of focus
content accessibility interaction
accessibility device accessibility
inclusive representations and
application diversity
so i'm gonna touch on most of these
in this talk here but for this first
part i'm actually going to just focus on
the interaction accessibility and the
device accessibility as it relates
primarily
to people with limited mobility
so first is device accessibility so
one of the reasons why vr is so
inaccessible is because the devices that
we have to use to implement to interact
with underlining
experiences and applications like i
mentioned before
make a lot of assumptions about users
and their abilities
and this gonna this facilitates the
needs for more customizable hardware but
also more
just accessible hardware in terms of
looking at things that
people can do already so like what
devices do people already use
and then how can we integrate that with
more accessible technologies
so when we think about vr accessibility
there's this or when we think about vr
in general there's this really
er strong urge to actually want to make
things
kind of like as realistic as possible to
really embed
the user inside the virtual environment
and have really tight
mappings between what the user can do
and what the system
does in turn inside the virtual reality
system
but if the devices that we use to
actually be able to create this level of
immersion aren't accessible to people
then the whole system kind of breaks
down so we need to think about ways to
actually make the devices accessible to
people
because if they're not they won't be
able to engage in the systems in the
first place
um so there's been some work that's
looked at this um
for people who are blind for example so
this is a project
called the cane troller that was done at
microsoft research
a few years ago that was led by an
intern
um yuang who's now a professor at
university of wisconsin
essentially we're looking at well how
can you make interactions inside vr more
accessible to people who are blind
well you can actually create custom
hardware to allow people to have these
kind of tactile sensations or
feelings when they're actually
interacting inside of a virtual world
so this is a great project that um alexa
actually came the
couple years ago and actually um worked
on kind of like a follow-up to this
project and actually made some really
great improvements so
this is like one really interesting and
really useful way of thinking about
device accessibility it's like well how
can we create new things that allow
people to have new experiences
um i when i joined a team i you know
like i mentioned before for my
dissertation research i was really
looking at things from
standpoint of limited mobility so when
we came into this i was really looking
at these type of questions well
you know what accessibility varies to
people with limited mobility and counter
reusing vr systems so like just
commercial vr systems what barriers
might they encounter
and then for people who have used vr
systems what strategies have
they employed to try to overcome some of
these accessibility barriers
so to help us answer these questions we
ran this interview study we had 16
participants with limited mobility we
had a mix of in-person and remote
interviews
and we had a couple of people with prior
vr experience
the vr experience was nice to have but
we didn't want to
over index on that because it's just
really hard to find people
um who have either used vr and have
found it accessible to them
um so for the people who are actually in
person that came in and did the study
and the people didn't have and they
didn't have prior vr experience we
actually gave it an opportunity
to try out these three different vr apps
so one is like all space vr it's like a
social vr environment
oculus first contact you could think of
as like a tutorial type of thing to
teaching you how to use hand tracked
controllers and things
and then google earth vr which we just
thought could be an interesting
application for people to play around
with to get a sense of how they like the
vr experience
so from this paper that we published at
assets um just last year
um it was the conference was in october
we essentially identified
what we call these like seven vr
accessibility barriers so things like
setting up a vr system
putting on it taking off at hmd
adjusting the hmd head strap
cord management manipulating dual motion
controllers inaccessible buttons and
maintaining view
of the controllers were things that we
identified as just hey if somebody wants
to be able to interact with a vr system
just kind of like once they open the box
here are some of the issues that they're
going to have to deal with for trying to
think about somebody's
kind of concerns so i'm going to talk
not about all of these i just kind of
want to highlight a couple
and some of these you might look at it
might be like okay yeah that makes sense
but
why is that a concern or why is that
like a hci problem so
so for example we could just look at
things like you know adjusting the hmd
head strap
or and you can kind of tie this in more
broadly with putting on and taking off
the hmd
so in terms of like design and how we
think about these
things there's just some like functional
design thing so for example
this um p1 said uh one thing i noticed
is that the back strapping
is stick so it touches like my headrest
so a headrest that might be included on
a wheelchair or power wheelchair
so that makes it difficult for this
person to move their head for example so
just the way that this thing is designed
and it wasn't necessarily thought about
how you would design it so that it would
work well for someone who seated in the
wheelchair
can actually make it in their case
difficult for them to move their head
and have these other interactions
but it also kind of speaks to this
broader question that you're going to
have of
well like hey how do we create more
accessible type of like
wearable technologies more broadly for
people with physical disabilities
so it's not just a question of how can i
have something that
might interfere with my headset there
are people who might have difficulty
raising their arms above their chest for
example or lifting their arms head
lifting their hands above their head so
if we had these technologies that
presume a certain level of control and a
certain level of autonomy
how does that break down then if people
then have to understand
how people can't use this in a way that
they may have wanted to because the
technology just wasn't designed in a way
that makes it accessible to them like we
need to think more broadly around the
design of these technologies
not just for hmds but other types of
wearable technologies
that might be exclusion that might be
excluding people with physical
disabilities from taking part um
so there's another one that is more
relevant to some of the research i'm
going to talk about
after this is so let's thought about
manipulating dual motion controller so
unlike in a traditional desktop
computing sense where it's kind of like
you know
you kind of have one pointing implement
as the main focus of control so you
either have like a mouse or a trackball
or you're using your finger on a
touchscreen um in a vr environment you
could have two controllers and use both
hands to do
different things at different times but
that could also be challenging for
people
with limited mobility um so one of these
quotes here from
participant14 said i can only use one
hand for the controller so
i so i use my right hand to control one
of the sticks and i think having the
one-handed barrier is quite common for
people who have strokes um
and then another participant p2 here
that says like you know i just wouldn't
use it too much or requires coordination
it could be really frustrating
and kind of in tandem with this is this
notion that
hey these um these controllers
themselves aren't just used for like
their motion tracking
capabilities uh people also have to
interact with the individual buttons and
things on them to actually you know
perform these interactions so we have
one participant here
p6 and this is kind of represented in
the image here
it's saying it's like yeah i think
walking was pushing down so this is
walking in a virtual environment
um so you push one of the joysticks down
and then to do that i had to use two
hands and leave the other controller to
do it
as soon as i heard that you have to push
it down i was like yep nope that's not
happening
and that's primarily because people
might have low strength for example in
their hands or low dexterity so if
you're expecting people to be able to
hold and manipulate multiple buttons at
the same time while still holding this
controller
like participant six said that might not
be possible for them they might actually
have to like stop what they're doing put
another controller down and then use
both hands to just
press down the joystick right um
so when we ask people kind of like well
what are these what would be some things
that you might want to see like what
will
make these experiences more accessible
to you uh so some people mention things
like well just like alternative input
controls right so
if we can't make this assumption that
everyone who's going to use a virtual
reality system is going to have
kind of the availability to them of
having two kind of six degrees of
freedom
tracked controllers that they can use
all the time um
how could we do things with people how
can we do these interactions with
devices that people already use so if
someone uses a quad stick or they use a
series of switches or a
trackball how what's the possibility for
that and then other ones it's like well
how can we use other different types of
input modalities so how could we use
gaze input or voice input to allow more
accessible vr manipulations but even
with gaze and voice we're still not
there yet in terms of understanding
how would somebody for example fully
control a vr
interface or interact inside of a vr
environment
using strictly gaze or using strictly
voice is something that
we're just not sure yet how to make all
of those
interactions accessible given the more
limited input modalities that might be
available to some people
so one possibility and i think that's
really good and i know
um patrick carrington was here earlier
um in this
the quarter um it's to think about
charitable computing so
this is this idea that you know
shareable computing is really this
technology that takes advantage of the
space on or around a wheelchair
um as much as you know kind of like
leveraging
um on body and warm mobile technology is
what wearable computing can do
so essentially the idea is well how can
we bring interfaces and enter the
devices closer to people so that
these then devices can actually then sit
on places that are actually really
useful and really beneficial to the
person
who's using them so one thing that
we were looking at here oh the title of
the slide is wrong so
forget the accessible bimanual input
part that's coming later um
the question that we're actually looking
at here is it's um well how do we
leverage more traditional
2d input devices things that could fit
more comfortably on
the form factor of a wheelchair to you
know complete
more complex spatial interactions so
one thing we looked at what we thought
was actually a good example of this is
like virtual hand manipulations
so in a vr environment you could use
these touch controllers to perform
different type of
hand manipulation so you could do things
like make a thumbs up or grasp a cube
and use the controller to like throw it
or just drop it toss it in different
directions
so this is something in which there's no
really good design schemes right now to
say well how would i use a commodity
input device like
a joystick and a switch to be able to
perform
all these various types of virtual hand
manipulations it's something that
you know prior work that's looking at
like the design space of input devices
for example
doesn't really have great answers for in
terms of saying hey we have these
complex
interactions here's how you might want
to map this input device to this complex
interaction
so um so for example for this you know
we did like a user elicitation study
where we we got 21 participants for
limited mobility
once again this is happening in covet
time so we weren't able to actually do
this
in person but we actually did was use
the crowd listed platform that abdellah
lee
and others created to actually be able
to do this like remote use user
elicitation study
so we created 16 hand manipulations as
reference and what we did was we showed
them
each of these kind of like little short
videos slightly longer than the videos
you see right now the thumbs up and we
just ask people hey how would you
use a different types of input devices
to be able to
perform this gesture for example so in
our study
that i'm going to talk about now it's
like you know we ask people that's like
hey if you use a touchpad you know it
can sense
multiple concurrent touch points how
would you use that to perform these type
of gestures
and some of the things that we found
initially up well
to analyze before we get to that to
analyze this what we did was we looked
at the taxonomy of surface gestures
by robrock at all that looked at okay
hey we can analyze different gestures
that people make on the touch screen to
understand
kind of how people's mental models of
these gestures actually work
so some initial findings for example
that we have around this that speaks to
these notions of mental models for
example
are we looked at like discrete hand
gestures so we had things in our set of
16 total that were like four discrete
hand gestures so this kind of like
you know index plus extended finger
closing a fist a thumbs up
and what we found was that when we were
analyzing people's answers for how they
would perform these gestures
41 which was the most popular um
or the most common results were abstract
gestures so
abstract gestures are ones in which
there's really no mapping between
what the person does with the gesture
and how that relates
to what the actual referent or the the
end result is going to be
so in this case we had people doing a
lot of things for example like
oh to you know to make the to make a
thumbs up i might tap
on the screen three times consecutively
or i might do
a tap and then a swirl or something
but those gestures don't have really any
indication of
what's going on with the actual hand and
you compare that to these kind of like
grasp and release gestures
um hand manipulations that we looked at
57 of those were metaphorical so meaning
that the gesture actually
is more tightly bound or tightly related
to what the actual hand manipulation is
doing
so an example of that for example is we
can look at these dichotomous reference
so
meaning that there's the same reference
but kind of like in reverse in this some
in some situation so for example we can
have an action that's just like well how
would you grasp an object
using this virtual hand and then we can
ask well how would you release it
and this speaks to this kind of
metaphorical gestures that people were
referring to so
um so somebody p16 for example would say
so to grasp the cube
they said they would squeeze their
fingers on the touch pad together to
grab the object
and then to release they would kind of
just do the opposite or the reverse
of the grass gesture which in this case
would just be to extend their fingers
um to release so
this is a study that we've actually been
really interested in it's something that
we think is really useful
um here's kind of a diagram that shows
all the 16 different
hand manipulations that we implemented
and it's useful because what we want to
be able to understand here
and kind of different than what you
might do in a typical user elicitation
study is where you actually want to
come up with some type of consensus and
say like
hey this is the gesture that would work
really well to perform this action
um people with disabilities have so many
different ways that they interact with
objects and they do things
typically to relate well to their own
ability so we're not necessarily looking
for you know consensus and saying like
hey this is what people are using but
what we're
instead looking for is like well what
are these mental models like
so you know are there categories of
different hand manipulations that might
be
harder for people to understand how they
would actually implement those
uh so for example what we found was that
these translation ones so like
move forward move backwards people are
able to come up with really
easy gestures for those because they
might say
just directional swipes for example
might be good enough for people to
understand like okay if i want to move
something backwards or forwards i might
just swipe up and down for that
interaction
but like i mentioned before these kind
of more um
discrete gesture type of things in which
there's not a really great mental models
for like how do you do a thumbs up on a
touchpad
um we might have to think about ways
that uh create more accessible mappings
for those different types of
interactions
so this is like one example of ways that
we need to think about how commodity
input devices can be used in a way to
create
much more complex expressive
interactions when we actually get to vr
and different type of augmented reality
interfaces
um so some of the takeaways that we had
from not just the study
that i just mentioned but the the assets
paper uh this actually comes from the
assets paper so
just a couple of things in terms of
design so one thing that's really
important is this notion like designing
for interdependence so
interdependence is kind of a design
framework in which you don't think about
how a person would do something
independently
you actually try to understand
and acknowledge that people with
disabilities often work with
other people a lot of the times to do
different things so people might work
with caregivers and friends and families
um
for lots of different interactions and
what we heard from our participants was
that
hey when thinking about how to create
more accessible vr systems just don't
think about the one user to one person
think about
the ecosystem that that person is in how
could you help or how could you involve
caregivers and family members in the
process to make these devices and
systems more accessible to them like how
people work together to do certain
things
um design for customization really comes
to this question of saying
you know we really need input controls
and interaction methods that people can
really take advantage of
create more bespoke solutions but at the
development level we really need to
think about
how to enable that level of flexibility
and control
um design for accessibility so this is
really just meaning more towards like
ability right so if you're thinking
about different ways that
people might use a system you really
want to put the ability part first and
really
put that in the foreground and then the
last one is this that design for
diversity
one of the things that came up in our
interviews with participants was that
people felt that there was this
expectation that you know if something
was
un was inaccessible to them that that
was kind of like okay like it was just
like well this wasn't made for you
you know like why would you want to be a
part of this experience this is an
experience for people
who can walk or experience for people
who can throw and if you can't
walk or throw then you should want to be
able to engage in these experiences
what we found is that like you know
people want to interact with vr systems
in all types of ways so
don't kind of make the assumption that
like hey what matters the most is just
immersion or what matters the most is
embodiment in these certain situations
really consider what people want and how
they're going to interact in these
different type of
situations
so the next thing i want to talk about
is this notion of interaction
accessibility so
like i mentioned and when we talked
about device accessibility
vr much more than these traditional
systems
think about physical input and output
and
it's really bad in terms of
understanding how people with limited
mobility can translate what their
physical actions are into the actions
that the system can
interpret and use in a in a way to make
their interactions
easier and more enjoyable to use so
when we make these vr inputs and outputs
like we increase the fidelity of them
essentially what we're doing is that
we're importing a lot of the things that
are inaccessible
inaccessible about the physical world
and we're importing them
into the virtual world so if there is an
action
or something that was hard for you to do
in the virtual world but
in the real world but now the virtual
world expects you to perform that action
the same exact way
we're just now making the virtual world
just as inaccessible
as the as the real world um so we need
to really think about
these inaccessible methods and user
interfaces that can work well for these
more accessible devices that we also
create
so another example of this for people
who are blind or low vision is this
system called seeing vr
which is essentially this collection of
enhancements
that will allow people to to allow
people with limited
vision to be able to have more
accessible interactions in vr
by doing things like having edge
enhancement having magnification lenses
things like that and again where i'm
really looking forward is how does this
work for people of limited mobility
so um i was really interested in this
question of accessible bimanual input
and one of the participants actually has
this quote so
um and talking about using two hands to
perform actions in vr they said i'm not
sure that
that would be possible for me to do them
simultaneously if i had to do i could do
it one-handed
but if i had to do both hands at the
same time that's not going to work
so you might have people for example who
are amputees that might have access to
one
arm or one hand you might have people
who might have
more strength or more movement and one
hemisphere of their body compared to the
other
so people might prefer to just use a
single controller to be able to do these
input manipulations but then the
question becomes well how do we do these
kind of like
complex bi-manual input actions if i
just have a single input modality
um so this is the question we ask so i
have the great intern ramona yamagami
who's a
uh phd cam at university washington who
was intern with me last summer and we
kind of explored some of these areas so
once again as you know how can we allow
people to control bimanual interfaces
with unimanual input
so what we did is we started off with
this kind of popular framework the
guillard framework for this asymmetric
division of labor
so this really tells us is that like hey
we can really think about it as like
there's only really a few
types of bimanual interactions so
there's symmetric end phase in which
both hands do the same
role at the same time so you could think
of that as like um jumper roping both
hands are kind of like working
in tandem on the deduction action um
symmetric out of phase is that both
hands do the same action but at
different times so if you're thinking
about something like
climbing a rope or a ladder one hand
might go and then the other hand might
go
so both hands are doing the same action
just at different times
asymmetric coordinated is when both
hands are working together
on like a single object so you could
think of that as something like you know
you're cutting an apple one hand holds
the apple while the other hand is kind
of actually doing the slicing
and then you can think of asymmetric
uncoordinated as two hands are just
doing
two different things and they're not
coordinated with each other so that
could be
like in a gaming scenario it could be
you know you hold a shield with your
left hand
and you hold a sword when your right
hand and in theory you know you could
bash in one direction with the shield
while swiping with the sword
so there's really no way to identify
kind of what the two things are doing
um so if you're really thinking about
like well how can we create interaction
techniques for this space well you can
maybe think about it along the spectrum
of like well how much autonomy do you
want the user to have right
so you can really think it's like okay
if i have a spectrum between less
autonomy to more autonomy what can i do
with that
so with less autonomy in terms of the
user actually having some input and
what's going to happen
maybe you say hey if the user encounters
a bi-manual task
we just automatically perform a task for
them or we give them the option to
automatically perform the task
um so that could be something like you
know hey you encounter a ladder
you can just automatically climb the
ladder we're not going to have you do
the two-handed interaction piece
uh similarly if you want something
that's more in the middle you can maybe
do something where you actually infer
the output
of the two hands given input from the
one hand so if i know what one hand
with one hand is doing could i then
infer what the other hand should be
doing based off the
input that i'm getting from the one hand
and then if you really want to give
people a lot of autonomy maybe you could
do something like use an alternative
input method so maybe you can use the
headset or that eye gaze
as something to compensate for not
having the other hand uh so what you
could do then
is you know whatever designs or
interaction techniques you come up with
on the spectrum from less to more
autonomy
then you can kind of overlay those with
you know what's happening with these
different type of
interaction methods so in this case i'm
going to go through an example of saying
like okay well if i have
automatic inferring or alternative what
does that look like for
symmetric autophase interactions um so
for example if i wanted to infer the
location of a virtual hand in this
symmetric out-of-phase thing
perhaps what i'll do is i'll create a
system in which the virtual hand
kind of always just mimics the direction
speed and distance
of what the real hand is doing so if the
real hand performs some movement
up to climb the ladder and win a certain
distance i'll just have the virtual hand
mimic that interaction by going the same
distance and speed and everything else
and then i could just have a snap to
kind of like whatever the coast closest
like interactable object is
um so the benefits of that is like you
know could be less fatigue um
it could be you could perform more
movement simultaneously but once again
the user has less control and then
similarly maybe for the alternative
input you say things like hey well the
real hand is going to operate this but
let's say i want to use like the hmo
headset to identify the location of the
virtual hand
so this could give you more autonomy or
control you can perform more movements
but if you really want to get into
complex interactions your alternative
input might need
similar degrees of freedom as the hand
you could have issues with overloading
and it could be not as accessible as
some you to some users
so an example of that could be this
situation
here so on the right is
uh momona and she's essentially using
climbing kind of like with one hand
and then what she's doing is using kind
of the location of the
hmd kind of like the gaze offset of the
or the head tracked offset
of the hiv to be able to understand
where the next virtual hand should go
so this could be like a really great way
to say like hey if you only have one
hand available to you great
we could just you know use some other
different type of input device and use
that as a way
to then control what the other hand
should be doing
okay all right so i'm going to skip that
because i'm a little i'm running low on
time here and i want to get to
questions and answers so i just kind of
want to talk about future opportunities
that the
part of the uh the accessible my design
paper that i really have a chance to get
into
so just really briefly so the other ones
on the list for content accessibility
so this is really looking at ways let's
say like hey we don't really have
agreed-upon methods to make content
accessible in vr
and we don't so you know and there's
trickle-down effects to that so we don't
know what type of metadata is necessary
we're not sure what standards we should
have
and then we're also not sure how we can
allow people to apply
these accessibility options post hoc so
these are all things in terms of like
well how do we actually make the content
of a vr environment so you can think of
something like a 3d video for example
like how would you make a 3d video
accessible to somebody who might be
blind or low vision
or to somebody with limited mobility who
can't move their head to see what's
going on in the scene
there's another thing here about
inclusive representations which is
really important so this idea that
you know vr has a lot of embodied
experiences and the people
usually embody these type of virtual
avatars
so what's the question then of how do
people with disabilities want to be
represented in these spaces how does
that embodiment work if
your avatar has varying diff um very
different abilities than what you
possess
so if you're a person who uses a
wheelchair
and doesn't walk but you have to embody
an avatar that does walk and has use of
both hands and things like that
is that actually an immersive experience
for that person does that actually
create something that they find
enjoyable or what they actually prefer
different types of mappings different
types of representations
um and then the last thing here is
really about like application diversity
so vr provides these opportunities to
kind of
do different types of application types
so you could do things like virtual
orientation and mobility training for
people who are blind or low vision
you could like you know recreate a
virtual city and have them
actually you know practice navigating
walk to work or walk into a new
doctor's office or something but
automatically actually having to do it
in person
you can democratize rehabilitation and
physical therapy more easily
and you can also think about
virtualizing existing digital tasks so
instead of having something like
20 actual physical monitors to get as
much
you know screen space as you can maybe
just replace all these physical monitors
or virtual monitors and does that make
things more accessible to people because
then they have more control over
how they move this virtual content
compared to this physical content
um so just kind of to wrap up in
conclusion here
really you know kind of what i wanted to
talk today about and demonstrate was
just that
you know people with limited mobility
are going to encounter a lot of
accessibility barriers when interacting
with vr systems and it's really
important to
really be mindful and think about what
barriers they may encounter and how we
can really start to designing more
accessible systems
and not just like accessible in terms of
like compliance not just like
hey a person can do this thing so i just
called it quits like how do you really
create
enjoyable immersive expressive
experiences in vr
for people with disabilities i mean when
you're designing this like think about
ability
when you're designing these interactive
systems focus on what people can do and
leverage that as much as possible
and then i really try to ensure that
these systems are designed to promote
equity
for people with disabilities moving
forward
so that's it for me um so i'll be happy
to answer any questions
excellent thank you martes thank you uh
for so for panelists feel free to just
submit questions excuse me panelists
feel free to unmute and just ask
questions for
uh those who are in the audience please
feel free to submit your questions on
the google format and i'll proxy them
just to start out with one um
traditional accessibility research tends
to go for software solutions to software
oversights right the
software has uh been designed with some
very strong uh ability assumptions and
then they're
they're too strong right they're they're
not the right ones and
when i what i see in your uh
in your talk is software responses to
both
software but also hardware oversight so
i'm i'm just kind of curious about
well what should we be doing on the
hardware side
right can if we if you were to given
sort of free reign to
redesign hardware for vr
would you have wound up at the same sort
of destination for the thing that you
know oculus etcetera should have
deployed
or would you have wound up with
something quite different and what would
it have looked like
yeah so that's a great question so i
would say you would definitely wind up
with something much different i mean i
think the
input devices so one of the things that
we're trying to leverage in the work
that we're looking at
is how can we take input devices that
people already have
already have familiarity with they're
already experts in that
and how can we leverage those to the the
biggest extent possible so for example
there's people who use like quad sticks
like so people who might be
paralyzed from the neck down you might
use caustics step and puff devices
things like that
and the question would be okay well we
have these kind of more lower fidelity
input devices and the question is well
how do you make those work in these kind
of more complex scenarios and the
question
and answer right now is just like you
know we're still just not sure you know
i think a lot of the things that we're
having around these type of
assumptions are that like hey i'm
expecting that you can move your body in
such a way
and that your kind of body will take
over these for these like more implicit
interactions right
and i think that what we're trying to
figure out is how can we create things
that allow people
to customize their setups to the
greatest extent possible
so an idea for example might be if a
person has limited
upper body mobility but let's say that
can actually move their legs and feet
quite well
why not give them the opportunity to say
put motion tracked
kind of devices on their feet instead
and now they can use their feet as kind
of like a proxy for what the hand
controls should be and instead just use
that input modality instead
then similarly you know other people may
not be able to use their feet but maybe
they can use something else so then
maybe they're saying like oh maybe i
will put this on my shoulders or
somewhere else where they have a lot of
degrees of freedom of control
so i think it's really going to be about
how can we democratize the
availability of input devices to the
greatest extent possible
and then how can we once we understand
what the possible
range of input devices are how can we
then start creating more accessible
interaction techniques and things like
that on top of those to take advantage
of them to the best extent possible
one is who's asking
have you noticed any differences in
studying accessibility in ar versus
accessibility in vr
and are there what are the
considerations between the two types
yes that's a great question so um so i
haven't done
a lot of explicit investigation on this
mostly like i said before
the covet pandemic has really hampered
our ability to actually be able to
you know go to go to people with
disabilities and actually understand
their preferences and you know what
things they do in real life
um but i will say like for example the
difference one of the differences is
that
you know the virtual reality virtual
reality environment the developers in
some sense control everything
every pixel is is a sunway generated
for some action so we can have a lot
more control over a virtuality
environment where
as an augmented reality there's a lot
more there's a lot of there's a
tighter fit between the physical world
and the digital content
so for example you might have a set of
digital content that you've anchored
to a physical object so like hey when i
look at this table i'm going to see this
content but i actually have to be near
this table to actually get access to it
so things like you know how do i access
content that might be spatially far from
me is a problem that in the ar
environment you would definitely think
about but in the vr environment we could
come up with
all of these different ways to kind of
like overcome that right we can make
people's like arms stretch really far
or we can like really just like expand
the screen or rotate the environment
around them but
if i'm here and there's really something
over there that i need access to
and if i can't either physically get
there or if there's other things that
are keeping that information from being
accessible to me
that's going to be a problem and i still
think that there's this broader notion
of spatial computing or spatial input
in which you know if we're expecting ar
systems to be able to use like hand
tracking for example so like on the
the latest hololens 2 from microsoft
there's a lot of great hand tracking
features that they have there where
people can actually use their hands to
manipulate the holograms
but once again what if you're a person
who doesn't have the fine motor control
in your hands to be able to perform
these interactions
then what's the opportunity right like
how do we then make those
interactions accessible to you even
though the kind of default
you know implement isn't you know
wouldn't work well for that person
michael can i jump in with a question
here um
so i i i have the luxury of getting to
meet with you in the next half hour so i
i'm asking a question that's for the the
students who are on the line because i
i think you presented so many amazing
ideas um for those of us who are
actually building and studying
and this on a daily basis what do you
think are a couple
just low-hanging fruit starting points
us so many good ideas like we've got
people here that can
that can test a lot of these where where
can we help yeah no
i think that's great so yeah so i think
there's one thing that for example
they're really interested in is
understanding this kind of like ecology
of devices and understanding how well
how best to implement those and use
those within a vr
scenario so i think i think there's
always this push and motivation to drive
to say like well how can we create
something new how can we create
something that
hasn't been done before and i think for
example a lot of people in the
disability community are like
this thing works really well for me if i
could use this thing like
all the time for all these different
situations i would prefer to do that
so part of it is like understanding like
hey if a person
uses a quad stick or a sip and puff
device and we're just like
use that as like just a constraint and
say like hey a person who's paralyzed
from their neck down
uses this device implement and they
still want to be able to have a great vr
experience like what does that look like
how like how can we really take this
like device of one or user one type of
scenario
and then really start to think about how
to design those type of
situations for them i think for example
if you're interested in working
with solutions for people who are like
blind or have low vision
i think there's still these like really
open questions around like
how do you create like uh what is like
the screen reader
equivalent for like a vr environment
like what's the voiceover
that's going to exist when people start
to think about
vr scenarios so i wouldn't necessarily
say these are like low-hanging fruit in
terms of like the
how you would actually get to solutions
for these but i think that in terms of
just like
the problem space i think kind of like
trying to identify
how we can best leverage what people can
use right now
and then try to understand how that can
how that can be leveraged in a vr or an
ar context i think could be
quite useful to people and then i think
once we kind of have that understanding
then i think we can actually start
building on top of that and actually
then start to think about
different ways to you know to create
systems on top of that so like for a
really brief
example um one thing's that we're trying
to partner with another research team at
uh
at msr they have this platform that they
call jack dac which is essentially this
hardware platform that allows people to
be able to plug
just any different type of input module
into it so the idea could be for example
you know how could you how could we
democratize what we think about a
what is a controller really and if we
think about as a controller it's just
like this
prefabricated set of buttons and
triggers and
you know joysticks and things like that
but if somebody can say like you know
what actually i want a platform in which
i could put things like
near my headrest so i could go like this
to be able to hit things i want to be
able to put things in my feet so
when i hit them these things happen so
how can we kind of like
you know expand our role of what we
think the input
ecology could look like um to be more
accessible inclusive to people i think
could be really powerful
i have a comment sort of related to what
you just said um
it seemed like as you were laying out
your framework a lot of it
was um about input um
when you said do it was largely what
people
could you know move and cause to happen
as inputs to a system whereas a lot of
times accessibility
is about ability to sense um
and so you get the blind or low vision
the
the deaf or hard of hearing and so forth
um
do you have any thoughts about how
vr um is useful in one versus the other
or how you would
make things accessible and available to
people it
with the input disabilities versus the
output disabilities
yeah no yeah that's a great question
yeah so
yeah i think they're both i think
they're both tricky so i think like so
for example for
of these kind of like output kind of
questions
you know for example with people
different sensory disabilities so for
example
um if you take sound for example and one
way we might think about
well how do we make sound more
accessible in a virtual reality context
could be doing things like oh we can
actually have these kind of like
different types of um
augmentations or substitutions so how
can i take something that's that's
available in one sense and then
augmented or substituted with a sense
that the person does possess
so if there's if a person's deaf or hard
of hearing and we want to make the sound
that's available to vr environment more
accessible to them well how can we take
that input that output channel and then
transfer that to something that's more
tactile or haptic or how can we turn
into something that's more visual
but not in a way that like is too
overwhelming or overloading to the
person
on the screen and be able to do these
different things and i think similarly
for
people who are blind or low vision in
which you might say like well how do you
how do you describe a complex virtual
scene to someone who's blind like
what's the what's the nature of that
interaction i think right now with
2d interfaces we have this kind of more
like scanning
type of mental model of it where it's
like okay you started kind of like the
top of the document and you kind of
go down and you go across lists or
tables and things like that but
if i just have an entire virtual world
ahead of me how do i present that
information to a person who's blind and
know
like well what are they trying to look
for what's important to them what's the
most relevant thing is it
based off the environment or is it based
off the task they're trying to perform
is it based off the uh the people around
them and how that's going to influence
what they can do so
it's not something that i myself i'm
more interested in like the input side
and just in terms of the research
i do but i know a lot of people are
thinking about these kind of like more
like
output questions that you ask like for
people different sensory disabilities
what can we do in that space so i think
it's something that people are working
on but
i think there's still a lot of open
questions there
thanks i noticed we're coming to the end
of the hour so i'll just sort of
summarize as food for thought some of
the other questions that came in there
we got a question about um non-physical
uh ability differences like people who
deal who are dealing with trauma
fire fight or flight responses we had a
question about design process thinking
about how would one
how one would go about creating these
experiences if you don't have direct
access to people
with limited ability to develop empathy
or test with
um you know we have a question around
balancing accessibility and commercial
interests
um and and so on so a few other
questions uh but
we'd all like to thank you all for uh
thank you martha for for joining us
and uh we look forward to chatting with
you and either in person or remotely as
as
the future uh pretends so thank you so
much
yes thank you so much for having me and
if anyone has any questions or
wants to collaborate anything please
feel free to reach out we're always
happy to
to talk to people so
you